So I know that it's popular with much of the
Trump is right.
And even actually with some people on the
left could pretend that
there was never any Russia story to do revisionist
history.
But of course, sensible people know that that's
not the case.
There was a Russia story.
It just never was.
Nor did we expect it to be video evidence
of Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin personally
colluding and planning things or whatever
the case may be.
But we've seen Trump do everything from notify
Russia and advance that they'd be bombing
a runway in Syria leading to that runway being
cleared and then bombed.
And then of course, re operational within
a few hours to Donald Trump pulling troops
from Syria exactly in line with what it is
that Russia would want to everything in between
in those two years, uh, between those two
events, we don't have to revisit everything
today, but now we have once again, just another
little incident, another data point in the
Russia story because we have now learned,
and it is being, uh, really confirmed by Donald
Trump that Donald Trump notified Russians
before our own congressional leaders that
he planned to go after ISIS leader Abu Bakr
al-Baghdadi over the weekend.
This was a huge news weekend and we're going
to have so many different things to talk about.
But one of the things that happened is that,
uh, Al Baghdadi, uh, killed himself, was killed,
killed himself.
You know, this, right?
I guess it depends technically how you want
to describe it or what you think is most important
about the narrative.
Uh, al-Baghdadi is, or was an ISIS leader.
The military went after him in a raid, clearly
meant to tamp down some of the very much deserved
criticism of Donald Trump for the potential
resurgence of ISIS.
As a result of Donald Trump's decision to
completely haphazardly encountered to all
military advice, pull American troops from
Northern Syria a couple of weeks ago.
The details are that al-Baghdadi died after
igniting a suicide vest that he was wearing,
killing not only himself, but three of his
children.
I mean the, the sick nature of, of all of
this is a truly stunning.
Now there were lots of theatricals involved,
not only in Donald Trump's speech about what
took place, but also in Donald Trump's supposed
situation room photo while the operation was
taking place.
But I'm going to get to that a little bit
later.
It deserves analysis on its own.
So if we remove ourselves completely from
the history with Russia that Trump has and
just pretend is a normal president, typically
presidents will inform our own congressional
leaders regardless of whether they're Democrats
and leaders or Republicans or vice versa,
or the same party, whatever the case may be.
When there is a high level military operation.
For example, when president Obama went after
Osama bin Laden speaker of the house, Nancy
Pelosi, uh, about would have been whoever
was speaker at the time.
No, it was a banner at the time or at Paul
Ryan.
Now I'm, I don't remember.
Congressional leaders were notified in advance
that this was going to be going on.
We now heard in this case from speaker of
the house, Nancy Pelosi, that the Russians
were notified in advance of the attack, but
congressional leadership, like speaker of
the house, Nancy Pelosi was not Donald Trump
allegedly told two Republicans, Richard Burr
and of course Lindsey Graham, a Looney Lindsey
about the plan to attack.
Donald Trump confirms that he didn't tell
Nancy Pelosi saying, quote, no, I didn't.
I didn't do that.
I wanted to make sure this kept secret.
I don't want to have men lost and women, I
don't want to have people lost.
Now there is a lot to unpack just in that
statement.
I don't want to dig too far into it, but you
know, Trump implying that if you were to tell
Nancy Pelosi, all of a sudden it would leak.
I don't know of any history of Nancy Polosi
leaking plans for sensitive military engagement
or anything like that.
It's absolutely disgusting to insult the speaker
of the house in this way, absent any evidence,
but let's not dwell on that because there's
much more to discuss.
Once again, all roads lead to Russia and Putin
and Trump admits this.
Trump bragged about it.
Trump said, we spoke to the Russians, we told
them we are coming in and they said, thank
you for telling us we were going to notify
congressional leaders last night, but we decided
not to do that.
Okay.
This is not hypothetical.
This is not speculative.
This is Trump saying, I told Richard Burton,
Lindsay Graham, I told the Russians, I decided
not to tell congressional leadership.
So to go back to Donald Trump's idea, once
again, that Nancy Pelosi might somehow compromise
the mission for some reason that he can't
defend with facts.
When Barack Obama went after Osama bin Laden,
he didn't tell Pakistan because telling them
might've compromised the operation.
And after the faculty on Panetta, who was
the defense secretary at the time, explained
why that was done for operational security.
You keep it, you keep knowledge within us
borders, if not physically, you know, metaphorical
borders, uh, who knows what is in the works,
needs to be kept compartmentalized.
But leadership needs to know, right?
But Trump continues in this completely ridiculous
way acting like everything is being done either
for the approval of, or even worse, the direction
of Vladimir Putin.
And it's not conspiratorial.
I mean, listen, we know the Russian military
is on the ground in Syria knowing in advance
that the United States is going to be doing
this allows them to know, here's an opportunity
to potentially observe elements of the operation
or movements or signals intelligence that
we now knowing that this operation is taking
place, we can start building our understanding.
The Russians can have the methods and systems
that are used by the United States.
It's just a national security threat.
That's all that it is.
And Donald Trump, uh, you know, sadly due
to scandal fatigue, Donald Trump probably
will not get the attention he deserves over
this negative attention that is.
But it's the continuing trend of putting our
troops and our systems and our intelligence
operatives at risk.
And it appears that much of this has been
theater stage to make Donald Trump look good.
And the way that Donald Trump, listen after
this took place.
Donald Trump's absolutely diluted, you know,
narcissistic, I don't even know what words
to apply to it.
Speech about what took place, wanting to be
Obama, right?
For all the disdain Trump has Obama, that
was a speech he gave PR.
I'm not going to play any of it for you.
Where he wants to be like Obama making absurd
claims.
Like he's the one who recognize the danger
of Osama bin Ladin before anybody else because
he mentioned them in the list of like 50 things
that are not good, uh, in the nineties or
something like that, saying that getting al-Baghdadi
is bigger than getting Osama bin Laden.
I mean it's like we can argue about each of
these things on the merits, but that's not
even the point.
The point is this is diarrhea of the mouth
from someone who just can't help themselves
in making everything about themselves and
how they look and that's exactly what we're
going to talk about next with regard to this
absolutely ridiculous situation.
Room photo,